a day since the two men at the top of
government were found to have broken the
law since boris johnson became the first
sitting prime minister to receive a
criminal sanction
the first ministerial resignation the
justice minister david wolfson said in a
letter to the prime minister that he has
with considerable regret come to the
conclusion that the scale context and
nature of those breaches mean that it
would be inconsistent with the rule of
law for that conduct to pass with
constitutional impunity a resignation
that could mean momentum this is why i
want the prime minister to step forward
with his plan to recognize the scale of
the challenge we face the fact that the
trust has been eroded otherwise we will
get this drip feed effect of people who
no longer want to stay on the sidelines
but westminster is quiet in recess
most are still biding their time anger
curbed perhaps by world events for many
but not all
are you surprised that so few tory mps
are calling for the prime minister to
resign i don't need to wait and see how
many more fines are issued i think the
fact that there was
you know now
evidence of law breaking in the heart of
number 10 sufficient so i i don't know
what other colleagues are waiting for
maybe they haven't gone public maybe
someone already had i'd love it to be
enough but it wasn't enough to save matt
hancock or allegra stratton neither of
whom were ever investigated by the
police let alone fined by them
um
it looks like a bit of a different
standard being set if we're not careful
the prime minister remains out of sight
in checkers neither he or the chancellor
was seen today both men have apologized
and the cabinet have rallied he made a
mistake it was embarrassing and stupid
the prime minister's mortified
about it but i think there's a big job
for him to get on and and do uh on
behalf of the british people on behalf
of the
uh the world fighting this this this
cruel war
the chancellor took much longer than the
prime minister to release his statement
yesterday allies say he had a lot to
think about after would have been a
terrible couple of weeks he may well
have considered resigning but him going
would have put the prime minister's
immediate position into question that
prospect seems now to have passed but
this may well be a crisis delayed not a
crisis averted
more fines could come and sue grey's
report will be released in full after
the investigation
the prime minister and the man once
expected to succeed him are now in this
together
but timing in politics is everything
[Music]
the timing of putin's war the timing of
these fines in recess may well be what
saves the prime minister and his
chancellor for now ali fortescue sky
news westminster